using the python debugger in a terminal
in this video we'll learn how to use the
python debugger in the terminal
for this example
we're running code from the token
classification section
downloading the cornell dataset before
loading a tokenizer to preprocess it
check out the section of the course
linked below for more information
once this is done we try to batch
together some features of the training
data set by padding them and returning a
tensor
if we try to execute our scripts in a
terminal we get an error
note that we use pi torch here with
redundant source equal pt but you would
get the same error with tensorflow
as we have seen in the how to debug in
our video there are messages at the end
and it indicates we should use padding
which we're actually trying to do so
this is not useful and we need to go a
little deeper to debug the problem
fortunately you can use the python
debugger quite easily in your terminal
by launching your script with python
minus m pdb
and then the name of the training script
when executing that command you are sent
to the first instruction of your script
you can run just the next instruction by
tapping n and enter
or you can continue directly to zero by
typing c
and enter
once there you go to the very bottom of
the traceback and you can type commands
the first two commands you should learn
are u and d for up and down
this allows you to get up and down in
the traceback
going up twice we get to the point the
error was reached
the first command to learn is p for
print it allows you to print any value
you want for instance here we can see
the value of written tensors
or batch outputs to try to understand
what triggered the error
the batch outputs dictionary is a bit
hard to see so let's dive into smaller
pieces of it
inside the debugger you can not only
print any variable but also evaluate any
expression so we can look independently
at the inputs
or the labels
those labels are definitely weird
they are various size which we can
confirm by printing the sites using a
list comprehension
no wonder the token either wasn't able
to create an answer with them
this is because the pad method only
takes care of the tokenizer outputs the
input ids the attention mask and the
token type ids
so we have to patch the label ourselves
before trying to create a new tensor
with them
once you're ready to exit the python
debugger you can press q for quit and
enter another way we can access the
python debugger
is to put a breaking point in our script
we can do this using the
pdb.settrace method
as long as we import the pdb module at
the beginning of our script
saving
and then relaunching our script
with just python
we'll stop the execution at the breaking
point we set
we can inspect all the variables before
the next transaction is executed again
for instance here the features
typing n and enter execute the next
instruction which takes us back inside
traceback
one way to fix zero manually is to pad
all the labels to the longest
another way is to use the data creator
suitable for token classification
if you want to learn how to use the
python debugger in a notebook check out
the video link below